and now it's time for tonight's hashtag
war
this weekend San Francisco is being
invaded by Comedy Central's colossal
cluster fest a live comedy festival
featuring everyone from Kevin Hart to
Jerry Seinfeld some dick douchebag
named Chris Hardwick
and speaking of Seinfeld cluster fest is
going in to do a huge celebration of
Festivus the classic sitcoms alternative
holiday where attendees can participate
in the traditional airing of grievances
which in San Francisco probably includes
complaints like I got fired from that
app that I work for because I spilled
kombucha in the office ball pit but just
because you can't do ball pit can boot
camp bucho khofifah just because you
can't attend cluster effects in person
doesn't mean you can't get something off
your chest that's why tonight's hashtag
is air your grievances in five words all
right
examples might be can't attend Wonder
Woman screening and grumpy cat is not
DTF I'm gonna put 60 seconds on the
clock and begin
Doug the Magrib is not back all right
boy Chuck Kathy Griffin gives awful head
[Applause]
Oh
[Laughter]
for pirate movies too many all right
boys
Wendy Liebman I should have had a v-8
that's fine
Doug United dragging me onto flight yes
boy Chuck why did they cancel our list
fine
Doug five words not enough fine Wendy
shouldn't shop at Costco stoned hi boys
Doug baby Grune is growing up
Wendy midnight audience doesn't cheer
enough all right
yeah that's right guys you that
wasn't a cheer may be true really
yeah sometimes the truth is harder than
a cello blowjob